it will always going to land somewhere
and I doubt if they were short on offers
so but this particular move did surprise
me because personally I thought is going
to be Netflix but they've shown up here
and I think that they've got a fantastic
opportunity how big an opportunity do
you think it is though because it's kind
of untested as we heard from there we
don't really know how many people are
going to watch this program it's not got
a track record like Netflix has and
these are big personality they've got
big careers they're very established and
they were warned not just the cash but
they'll want people to watch absolutely
but I imagine the people Amazon have
done their numbers as well thinking
right they've obviously made a
significant investment to get them and
to make sure that this show is theirs so
they know their demographics they know
how they're going to get more viewers or
more subscribers into that so that's the
business side of it the thing that we
need to also consider really is that
previously we've had Top Gear BBC in
about 215 different countries but that's
been with Jeremy and James and Richard
well without their are they going to
still subscribe to Top Gear in those
territories so I wonder if there might
be a hole that this new show fills in
lots of other places in the UK I think
Chris's new BBC Top Gear will UM figures
beat the new showed us on Amazon but
globally I think that's where the play
is I want to ask a bit more about the
new Top Gear show in just a moment but
they're sticking with the old Top Gear
they don't the old team at least do you
think that it was inevitable the three
stayed together
it wasn't inevitable I think is highly
commendable that they did obviously
Jeremy tripped up pretty badly but the
other two signal okay we're staying with
him before did they realise that
actually there was no future without him
they came as a pack raft at all yeah but
what maybe I'm not inside their head
that maybe maybe but I jeremy is a you
know is a creative genius and he knows
his stuff
so and they do get on well and that
thing that everybody keeps talking about
that chemistry that that's the key that
I mean nothing's changed about Top Gear
when it goes on Amazon except it's not
Top Gear well that's what I want to ask
it will have to change they won't it or
will the original Top Gear have to
change is there room in the market for
two identical shows i I imagine not
I think they should called a new one web
gear something like that but the good
one thank you I'm gonna I'm gonna paint
it but with Chris's show I mean he's
obviously massively talented we all know
that he'll
something to shake it up I think he said
before they're going to try and retain
some added DNA of the existing Top Gear
we're used to but be prepared for what I
mean he does bring surprises although
that's why he is who he is so I think we
actually give debrie to great TV shows
coming up I hope so anyway
because Clarkson has got his old
producer from Top Gear sure so they're
gonna have a job on their hands making
something new because they are you know
they've been doing this for so long
they've got to reinvent the wheel
haven't they this is what I've always
been impressed about is that talking
about cars every single week and trying
to find something new about it to engage
audiences but I deeply suspect that
we've heard before that there's going to
be maybe more creative freedom with the
news show
I think Andy Wilman has also let slip
that maybe they want to actually make it
more about cars as well rather than just
staying on the messing around stuff is
that we might get more on the actual
cars themselves be got to be careful
there's only so many ways you can
describe an auto name before you fall
asleep all right so which one would you
watch Oh will you be watching well I'm
not signed up to the other one at the
moment it's not BBC's one easy for me
again well it's time to you to sign Matt
to Amazon oh yeah yeah but you know to
be completely honest I actually prefer
driving to watching TV okay